la vie sur terre c'est apparu il ya au
moins 3 8 milliards d'années et
peut-être même encore plus c'est du
moins ce que soutient un groupe de
chercheurs qui étudient depuis des
années des roches bien particulière en
bordure de la baie du sang on savait
déjà que ces roches sont parmi les plus
vieilles du monde
mais une fois taillé et poli et placé
sous un microscope
ils y ont découvert un univers caché ces
filaments rouges sont plus petit qu'un
cheveu et son fai d'hématite du fer
oxydé comme la rouille
pour matthew d'aude et dominique
papineau ces filaments seraient les
traces laissées par les toutes premières
formes de vie sur terre à l'époque ce
secteur rocheux de la baie du death on
faisait partie du plancher océanique
un milieu semblables à ceux qui existent
encore maintenant ses cheminées
hydrothermales ou fumeurs noirs crache
une eau riche en minéraux qui servent de
source d'énergie à des bactéries
cette activité chimique laisse
aujourd'hui dans la roche
le même genre de signatures que celle
que des chercheurs ont identifié dans la
baie de somme s'il s'agit bien de traces
de vie il faudra réécrire plusieurs
chapitres de l'histoire de la terre en
particulier le premier milliard d'années
notre planète s'est formée il ya un peu
plus de 4,5 milliards d'années
puis elle a lentement refroidi mais sa
première croûte rocheuses n'a pas duré
longtemps
âgé de moins de 100 millions d'années la
terre a subi un impact gigantesque dans
les débris en forme et la dune
il a fallu reprendre à zéro les si le
magma à la surface refroidir pour former
une nouvelle croûte rocheuses accumulé
une atmosphère puis des océans ou la vie
serait apparue il ya 3,5 milliards
d'années
c'est du moins le scénario généralement
reconnue ce que cette nouvelle étude
propose c'est de ramener la date à 3,8
ou même à presque 4,3 milliards d'années
à l'échelle géologique la vie se serait
développée à une vitesse fulgurante
l'idée bien sûr ne fait pas consensus
certains experts ne sont pas convaincus
que les fameux filaments rouges sont
origine biologique
d'autres s'interrogent sur les méthodes
de datation utilisé pour les roches très
ancienne
mais même l'hypothèse la plus
conservatrice à 3,8 milliards d'années
maintenant le même sens que plusieurs
études publiées récemment à mesure qu'on
trouve des indices de cette période
lointaine en réalise que la terre a pu
développer des conditions propices à la
vie très tôt dans son histoire et les
implications pour bien au delà de notre
planète
plus on comprendra à quel moment et dans
quelles conditions la vie s'est
développée ici et plus on sera ou
regarder et qu'elle indique chercher
dans l'univers sur mars par exemple on
croit qu'il ya 4 milliards d'années
il y avait un océan gigantesque et par
endroits l'eau s'est maintenu pendant
des centaines de millions d'années des
cible toute désignée pour les futurs
sont
mieux encore en ce moment même sous la
glace de deux lunes du système solaire
un repas autour de jupiter et en cela de
autour de saturne
il y aurait des as et andy kid avec tout
ce qu'il faut pour abriter la vie et
c'est sans compter les milliers de
planètes découvertes autour des étoiles
voisine plus on constate que la vie
s'est développée rapidement sur terre
plus on augmente les probabilités qu'il
y en est ailleurs